Kim and Kanye's baby via surrogate has
arrived plus what is the deal with
Selena Gomez and her mom
the latest drama and why were the Jonas
Brothers trending over the weekend hey
guys we are back after the long weekend
honoring dr. Martin Luther King jr. and
as you can tell there are a lot of
questions to answer today but one thing
we know for sure
Kenya's new bundle of joy is here that's
right Kim Kardashian and Kanye West are
the proud parents to another baby girl
their daughter arrived early Monday
morning at 12:47 a.m. via surrogate she
weighed a healthy 7 pounds 6 ounces and
we're told the couple were both in the
delivery room
another source tells et Kim was the
first to have skin-to-skin contact with
the baby and witness the birth Kanye
immediately held the baby right after
her now Kim shared an update with fans
on her app and says she and Kanye are
quote incredibly grateful to our
surrogate who made our dreams come true
while a source close to the family says
they are so excited and their new
arrival is an angel you guys will
remember in 2015 Kim suffered a
life-threatening complication during the
birth of Saint she told et recently she
couldn't feel more blessed to have the
means to grow their family through
surrogacy still not being able to carry
her own baby wasn't always easy on Kim
you know obviously you picked someone
that you completely trust and that you
have a really good bond in a
relationship with but it's still knowing
that I was able to carry my first two
babies and not you know my baby now that
is hard for me as for how North and st.
are doing now that there's another
sibling in the house Kim says they are
especially thrilled to welcome their
baby sister
so one Kardashian baby down and two more
to go people in the meantime let's name
the Kimye baby drop your some
suggestions in the comments section I'll
share my favorite one on tomorrow's show
alright guys switching gears now to the
latest drama between Selena Gomez and
her mom Mandy T Fey this time Selena's
mom is speaking out about her daughter's
decision to star in woody
upcoming film a rainy day in New York
she recently threw jabs on Instagram
after one user called for Selina to
write an apology about the Woody Allen
film Mandy replied to the comment
writing sorry no one can make Selina do
anything she doesn't want to I had a
long talk with her about not working
with him and it didn't click many stars
have publicly denounced Allen in the
wake of accusations he molested his
daughter Dylan Farrow allegations Allen
has denied but on Monday Selena's
co-star Timothy sha'lame announced he
was donating his entire salary from the
film to three charities hero on
Instagram this year has changed the way
he sees and feels about so many things
and added he doesn't want to profit from
his work on the movie as you guys can
imagine it's a complicated subject one
that Selena's mom Mandy takes a clear
side on and apparently Mandy also has a
very strong opinion about her daughter's
relationship a source recently told ET
that while she still isn't a fan of
Justin and Selena getting back together
she knows not to bring it up anymore for
the sake of her own relationship with
her daughter quote for the sake of their
own relationship they just don't talk
about it
Mandy knows that Selena is an adult and
she's going to do what she wants our
source added that the two have had their
ups and downs and they'll be able to
move past this one one day as well all
I'm saying is I told you guys I wasn't
sure about Justin and Selena either now
he sounds like a wedge between her and a
mom I don't like it well you know one
split we're still hoping leads to
reconciliation the Jonas Brothers the
fellas have fans freaking out over the
weekend after the ban reactivated their
Instagram account their original page
miraculously reappeared on Monday the
first time in four years last photo was
taken in 2013 the same year the group
went their separate ways and naturally
this got folk fired up they were the top
trending topic yesterday and even had a
Nick Jonas little shook he wrote whoa
now Nick of course has been busy with
his solo and acting career Joe has dnce
and Kevin started a family with wife
Danielle but many fans are wondering if
this now means a Jonas Brothers reunion
is on the way I
say and maybe time because here's what
Nick told me in 2015 about the prospects
of another job rose record as you know
is another Jonas Brothers album ever out
of the question I feel like I feel like
you guys could come back together and
put some yeah I don't know I think that
you know I'm happy to be doing my own
thing and we're all kind of happy to be
doing our own thing
we chose being a family first you know
and not a band
tough decision but it was the right
thing for all of us first I know what
you're thinking yes I still have the
same haircut
that's right anyways I think the reunion
seems way overdue and if I were Kevin
I'd be getting me out this dang house
with all these kids so hopefully we'll
get to the bottom of that soon all you
guys gotta do is make sure you're
subscribed to our channel and getting
notifications for the daily denne
because clearly I've got a lot of tea to
spill these days alright thanks for
watching guys and I'll see you back here
tomorrow
[Music]